Rapunzel was a beautiful child who grew into an even more beautiful young woman.
For a time, the witch took good care of her,...
...but when Rapunzel turned 16, she locked her in a room at the top of a tower.
When the witch wanted to speak to Rapunzel, she shouted,...
..."Rapunzel, Rapunzel, let down your hair."
One day, a young prince came by the tower.
"Come away with me," he said.
"We will get married."
"I would like to," Rapunzel said,...
..."But, how can I get down?"
Then she had an idea.
"Bring me some silk every time you come," she said.
"I will spin it into a rope."
Then one day Rapunzel, who was beautiful but not very clever, said to the witch,...
..."Why is it that you are much heavier than the prince who comes here every day?"
"You wicked girl!" the witch said.
"I shall put a stop to that."
And with these words, she cut off Rapunzel's hair.
She took the girl into the desert and left her there.
Then she went back to the tower and waited for the prince.
"You'll never find Rapunzel alive," the witch shouted at him.
"She's in the desert."
"By the time you find her, she'll be dead."
The prince, who was not badly hurt, rode away.
He looked everywhere for Rapunzel.
Then at last, many years later, he found her.
"I am now king," the prince said.
"You shall be my queen, and our two sons shall be princes."
He married Rapunzel and they lived happily together.